SIGNATURE.
GETTING WORD FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE THAT WILL TAKE PLACE
LATER AT 60 MINUTES FROM NOW
4:00 EAST COAST TIME.
THE TOP REPUBLICANS IN THE HOUSE
MINORITY LEADER, KEVIN
McCARTHY, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
$2 TRILLION, WOW I WONDER WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE?
WHAT WILL IT DO TO THE AMERICAN
WORKER AND WHAT WILL IT DO FOR
THE AMERICAN BUSINESS PERSON?
>> LET ME WALK YOU THROUGH THAT
AND BE HAPPY IT GOT DONE TODAY.
I WISH IT COULD HAVE GOT DONE
LAST WEEK.
AS YOU REPORTED MORE THAN
3.2 MILLION AMERICANS WERE LAID
OFF LAST WEEK.
THAT IS MORE THAN WE EVER HAD IN
THE GREAT DEPRESSION, SIX TIMES,
AND THE FINANCIAL CRISIS.
IT DOES A NUMBER IT PROVIDES
$40 BILLION TO HOSPITALS, NOT
JUST HOSPITALS BUT THE
VENTILATORS AND THE PP AND WHAT
THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY NEEDS.
PERSONAL CHECKS INDIVIDUALLY’S
FOR FAMILIES CAPPING OUT
STARTING TO PHASE OUT AT
$75,000.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT IT DOES FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT ARE DOING
SO MUCH TO HELP SHUT DOWN?
IT PROVIDES RESOURCES FOR THEM.
IT GIVES THEM ALONE BUT IF THEY
TAKE THAT MONEY AND PLAY THEIR
EMPLOYEE TO KEEP THEM WORKING
WHERE THEY PAY THEIR RENT OR
UTILITY, THAT IS A GRANT AND YOU
DON’T HAVE TO PAY THAT PART
BACK.
THE LARGER BUSINESS, LOW
INTEREST LOAN BUT ALSO TAX
ADVANTAGE TO PAY THEIR EMPLOYEES
PARTIAL.
RETENTION, WE WANT PEOPLE TO
STAY WORKING TO KEEP IN THEIR
JOBS.
THESE ARE THE KEY ELEMENTS OF
THIS BILL TO ACTUALLY HELP.
>> Bill: A FEW POINTS ON THE
SCREEN, $500 MILLION FOR
CORPORATIONS, $130 BILLION
HOSPITALS, $150 BILLION, AND
FOOD STAMPS, 1200 CHECKS FOR
MOST AMERICANS, $600 FOR THE
UNEMPLOYED AND ON AND ON IT
GOES.
TOM MASSIE FROM KENTUCKY HAD AN
ISSUE WITH THIS BECAUSE HE
WANTED EVERYBODY ON THE RECORD.
HERE IS WHAT HE SAID WHEN ASKED
ABOUT IT LAST HOUR.
>> THEY ARE TRYING TO COVER UP
THEIR VOTES.
THEY HAD ENOUGH PEOPLE TO PASS
THE BILL, BUT STILL REFUSED TO
HAVE IT RECORDED.
THEY TOLD ME THEY WERE TRYING TO
PROTECT MEMBERS.
>> Bill: THIS WENT BACK AND
FORTH OVER NIGHT AND YOU SAW HIM
PUT IT ON THE RECORD.
HE BLAMED SPEAKER PELOSI FOR
THAT SHORT PAUSE HE CONSIDERS
IT.
>> THAT IS UNFORTUNATE.
AS YOU KNOW WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
MEMBERS WHO HAVE THE VIRUS.
A NUMBER OF MEMBERS WHO WERE
QUARANTINED.
IF YOU ARE IN NEW YORK CITY, YOU
CAN’T MAKE IT DOWN.
THEY WILL FLY THROUGH THE MAJOR
AIRPORTS WHO HAVE PROBLEMS AND
PEOPLE WHO HAVE THEIR SPOUSES
WHO ARE PREGNANT, WHO HAVE THE
PARENTS WHO LIVED WITH HIM.
IT IS A CHALLENGE TO MAKE SURE
TO COME BACK BUT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THIS WAS PASSED.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE HELD THIS UP
BUT WE COULD HAVE GOT IT DONE
EARLIER IN THE WEEK.
BUT WE DO HAVE EVERYBODY ON THE
RECORD.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE WERE ABLE TO
DO?
WE DID NOT PASS IT WITH
UNANIMOUS CONSENT.
I WOULD NEVER AGREE TO THAT.
WE WERE ABLE TO HAVE THREE HOURS
OF DEBATE.
A VOICE FOR THOSE WHO WERE NOT
ABLE TO MAKE IT THAT COULD
ACTUALLY PUT ACROSS THE DESK HOW
THEY WOULD STAND ON THIS.
HOW THEY WOULD STAND ON THE
BILL.
WHAT HAPPEN HERE AND WHAT MASSIE
WAS ABLE TO DO IS BRING A NUMBER
OF PEOPLE BACK.
WE COULDN’T GET EVERYBODY INTO
THE CHAMBERS BUT NOW YOU HAVE A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE FLYING BACK TO
THEIR HOME CITY AFTER BEING
TOGETHER.
>> Bill: I ENTIRELY UNDERSTAND
AND RESPECT THE POSITION YOU
TAKE.
I GUESS WHAT HE IS SAYING
$2 TRILLION HAS NEVER BEEN HERE
BEFORE, AND WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
REFLECT THAT IN THE VOTE COUNT.
>> THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT WE WERE
ABLE TO ACHIEVE THAT.
BECAUSE YOU VOTED ON THE BILL.
YOU HAVE A RECORD ACROSS THE
DESK AND YOU HAVE THREE HOURS OF
DEBATE.
>> Bill: WE ALREADY HAVE BEEN
PHASE 4 BUT WHAT WOULD BE IN A
PHASE 4?
>> AND I HOPE ANYBODY TALKING
ABOUT A FACE 4 WOULD PAUSE RIGHT
NOW.
WE PASSED THREE BILLS.
AS YOU SAID, $3 TRILLION IN
BILLIONS AND THE OTHER BILL.
LET’S LET THEM GO TO WORK FIRST.
LET’S BE TARGETED ON WHERE WE
WILL SPEND MONEY.
LET’S MAKE SURE THIS IS ACTUALLY
WORKING IN THE PROCESS AND BE
SMART.
AND IF WE DO NEED MORE HELP, TO
BE ABLE TO USE THAT, BUT NOT